foreign
comes from Zach in Alabama he asks I'm
reading more and more about D
dollarization in countries moving away
from the US dollar as their basis of
international trade will this affect the
strength of the dollar and should I be
concerned about how I'm saving and
investing as a result of this
number one Zach you're spending too much
time on the internet
first and foremost okay
because you've gotten into the
conspiracy theory blanks here now what
is really going on okay I'm I'm
concerned with how it's going let me see
moving away from the US dollar as their
basis of international trade let me just
tell you
China and Brazil and Russia are the
three main players in this
they already don't use the US dollar
as their basis of international trade
Russia has its own currency so does
China and so does Brazil and there's a
conversion rate between that currency
and the US dollar
so many dollars equals so many in okay
and uh you know when you go to Mexico
a whole bunch of pesos equals a dollar
right like 20 of them so um
that's you know you got a conversion
rate from one currency to another what
these particular the three largest
countries and they're talking about
bringing in some of the oil countries
and as well in the Middle East uh are
doing is they're trying to come up with
one currency that they all use
and then that would be an international
trade converted back and forth to
Dollars much like Europe did with the
euro
which by the way
kinda didn't work
when that we had this exact same crap
when you're when uh
you know France did away with their own
currency the uh brexit was the big deal
whether the UK was going to get involved
or not and the Euro was traded all over
Europe and they did away with their
basic currency and now the U.S is just
gonna have we're gonna it's a One World
Currency it's the end times of
Revelation and this is what comes up
right okay but all it is is these
countries if they did all agree to use
one currency it'd be much like when
Europe went to the euro and then that's
going to exchange for the dollar back
and forth are those countries going to
be able to devalue the Dollar by doing
that no
because while they do take up a lot of
land mass they do not take up a lot of
the gross domestic product of the world
the United States still is the vast
majority of the gross domestic product
of the world still
China is Big Russia is basically
horrible and Brazil is in a failed
economy like times 10 and it's tiny as
far as economics go in other words like
I suspect I haven't looked it up but I
suspect Texas has a higher GDP than
Brazil
as an example for real I'm not kidding I
haven't looked it up but I bet you
that's true look it up I know it's got a
higher GDP than Egypt because I looked
that up one time I know it's got a
higher GDP than uh Sweden and about five
of the other countries that were talking
about natural gas crap a few years ago
because I looked that one up and that
was going to be the end of the world and
they were going to take over but they're
tiny butt little countries
and so when you put them all together
they don't have the muscle to take down
the dollar they just don't
mathematically it's arithmetic you know
you can't they just don't have it now
what they are going to do if they all do
put it together it's not a d
dollarization it's not doing away with
the dollar they've created their own
currency they're still going to have to
trade with the 800 pound gorilla which
be us okay and you're gonna have to
trade with us in dollars so you're gonna
whatever little currency you create over
there in your little fantasy world that
you live in you're still going to have
to trade it for dollars so it's not
going to take down the dollar is not
going to be worth anything and I don't
know how to invest because it's going to
collapse because freaking Brazil Brazil
seriously Brazil
I mean when you look at the math it's
humorous I mean and Russia we always
think of is like you know in the Rocky
movies or something like they're going
to come bomb the United States or
whatever and all this stuff but they're
when you look at their even though it's
a huge landmass their economic
production is pitiful
it's pitiful because communism sucks and
so it just doesn't create a lot of gross
domestic product you know and and so
really when you get into it that's what
you're gonna find so I'm am I worried
about this absolutely not absolutely
zero should you because Russia is
pitiful China has no labor force their
labor force is aging out because they
they stopped having babies
legally you know and so they have no
young labor force coming on so about
several economists are predicting that
their economy is really going to be in
deep due to in 20 years because there's
gonna be nobody to work
nobody do the work and so all the stuff
that they're China's creating right now
they're not gonna have anybody to do it
and and so this is a lot of just
fear-mongering it's it's it gets clicks
and Views and so the media
but should you be concerned about how
you're saving and investing no no I
wouldn't change a thing nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope I
wouldn't bet against America long term
it's a bad thing and it's not it's not
arrogance it's math
it's not like I'm blinded by the flag or
patriotism that's not it America does
some stupid butt stuff sometimes but uh
but even when we do we do it on scale I
mean
man
so no no no
listen I'm old and I'm getting tired
uh because when I first started there
was like a conspiracy theory that the
world was you've seen them all at this
point you know there's a guy here's one
this I was telling a friend of mine a
friend of mine was asking me about this
the other day and I said my answer to
him was
I read a book in 1982.
called bankruptcy 1984.
it was predicting the end of the U.S
economy in 1984 it was written by an
economist that was brilliant named Peter
Grace he was in charge of the grace
Commission in the Reagan Administration
and uh they were studying the increasing
national debt
and that the national debt was going to
cause the economy to collapse which I
think the national debt's stupid and out
of control okay but this guy said it's
going to hockey stick and the the
monetary policy is going to turn upside
down we've sucked all the cash out used
it for government stuff and the
economy's got no cash to operate on and
so it's going to collapse in 1984.
apparently wrong
and then another friend of mine wrote a
book called coming economic earthquake
didn't happen and then another guy wrote
a book talk about the collapse of the
economy and then another guy wrote a
book well then we had Y2 there's a lot
oh and the Watson because I was going to
collapse the economy and then there was
then when the planes hit the towers the
economy was not going to recover because
um 3 000 people died and Two Towers fell
in New York city so the entire U.S
economy was going to collapse as a
result of that and uh that went around
for a while and um and Silicon Valley
Bank
tiny little Bank over in San Francisco
that no one knew what it was except
venture capitalist has the power to
bring down the entire U.S economy it's
just asinine at some point it's like
okay
I George if I ever write the book on the
end of the economy would you please
smack me I'll do that just make sure you
plan it till after you're long after
your death so we can't blame you for it
in person and go no no boo boo no you're
wrong you would anyway you wouldn't
there you go I know he's dead but he was
stupid
No One's Gonna say that about you Dave
yes they will they say while I'm alive
so it's probably wrong